yesterday I had the honor of playing
Magnus in title Tuesday was December
12th and we had a really crazy game um
I've been Magnus twice in my life I was
trying to beat him a third time and
there's been games I've played against
him where he's just rolled me over but
this was definitely not the case and uh
I think there's a lot of lessons to take
away from this game I don't want to
spoil a result but I think it was super
super interesting uh Magnus was actually
on the Chas bro stream playing from his
phone next to Ari andari who's playing
on the computer so I might intersperse
some of his comments about our game in
this video and after I show my live
stream of the game I will do a full
breakdown and analyze all the crazy
things that were missed by both of us so
hope you enjoy oh I'm playing Santa
Claus here we go this was unexpected so
he didn't Rage Quit people were telling
me he Rage Quit
maybe delivering presents all over the
[Music]
world okay B4 of course let's play
whatever I know about
this I have a wing
gabit so I'm threatening this which
we'll probably
see uh what's the theory
here
E5
yeah I studied this a while
ago Queen E4
check this looks like the most
solid who takes
D4
sacking all the
ponds I have no idea what to
do
h
we have something that's
playable
KN D2 I take on a
four
for
ah I got
tricked never resign when you have a
knight
no I was trying to sell was stal me trap
but uh what a crazy game I felt like I a
chance to is
there Santa Claus gave me so many
presents all right let's take a look at
this game every time I play Magnus he
plays some different unexpected opening
this time it was a wing gabit which I
have studied in the past and the line we
ended up going
into I've checked maybe a few years ago
but uh not at all recently uh this move
D5 is a nice way to
basically decline the Gambit and it has
a trap that after takes takes if white
takes on B4 then Queen D4 check and
black is winning The Rook on A1 I
believe there was a game in the US
championships a few decades ago that
featured this opening trap um maybe one
of the shortest games ever in US
championship history uh but
unfortunately Magnus did not fall into
that trap and he played the best move
Knight F3 I played E5 and then he played
Pawn to C4 which when he played this
move I had some vague memories of
studying this position but I couldn't
remember exactly where my queen should
go and I was trying to figure out the
least worst Square for my queen um I
originally I wanted to play Queen A5 but
it seemed a little bit awkward there
because after Bishop
B2 then White's ready to take here or
take here and meanwhile if I play Queen
E4 check that only helps white develop
and then D3 is coming so I settled on
Queen E6 which turns out to be the best
move even though it blocks the bishop it
keeps E Pawn defended and B4 stays
defended by my Bishop so we continue
with D4 and Magnus just gives another
Pawn I took it with check he plays
Bishop E2 and I play Knight C6 he
castles and in this position I'm up to
two pawns but I kind of froze up I took
about like 40 to 50 seconds to play my
next move Knight F6 which I should have
just played quickly it's like a natural
developing move but I was just scared of
like Rook e one ideas and the prospect
of white taking here taking here and I
think in the Blitz game it just looks
like a scary position for black to play
a lot of potential for white to exploit
my lack of of
development so going forward he played
Rook e one and I managed to pretty
quickly complete development after
Bishop E7 Bishop D3 drop back with Queen
he takes I Castle so he won back a pawn
but uh I'm still up a pawn and I found a
nice Square for the Knight on B4 hitting
the bishop he played Bishop to A3
pinning my knight to my Bishop on E7 and
then I found this nice move Bishop to C5
and I think I was playing like pretty
well but I was just playing too slowly
after just 14 moves I'm already down
below a minute he's just used about 20
seconds off his clock but uh at least I
had a a decent position engine slightly
prefers back and with Bishop C5 I'm
trying to prepare to take on D3 which
would then defend my bishop and initiate
some trades so he avoids the trades with
Bishop F1 I play A5 reinforcing the
Knight he plays Knight D2 I play Rook d8
he plays Knight B3 and after Pawn B6 uh
he missed a pretty big opportunity here
now he played his next move in 4 seconds
he took on D4 maybe just trying to
pressure me on the clock but what he
could have done was take on
C5 and white actually has a really nice
sequence which would have been really
difficult to meet if he played this in
the game I would have to take back and
then he can take on B4 uh exploiting the
fact that my a pawn is pinned I'd have
to take back with my C pawn and then
there's a very strong move Knight
E5 and then my queen is hit Knight C6 is
coming which would be a triple Fork
hitting d8 D4 and
A5 and um yeah even though White's like
traded while down material I think uh
and also the engine thinks that this
would have been just a really really
nice option for white but I think given
the time
situation like he was more inclined to
avoid trades and keep things tense but
after Knight takes D4 then I was able to
essentially consolidate I developed my
final minor piece he takes on C5 I take
back he plays Knight B3 I defend the C
Pawn on The Rook to attack the queen and
after Queen C1 then I'm getting
initiative on my own I struck with
Knight G4 threatening checkmates in one
he defends with F4 and then I played
this move A4 and even though I'm still
significantly down on the
clock white is like close to just losing
here and I think there was a moment on
uh the chess Pro stream where Magnus
said something like getting
so he he was definitely not feeling well
and he took his first kind of extended
think of the game because the Knight is
almost trapped and if he moves to
D2 then it leaves F4 Pawn hanging now
what happened is he did play Knight D2
and I very quickly took on F4 which
turned out to be a pretty big missed
opportunity uh instead of taking on A4 I
had the opportunity to take on H2 and
yeah unfortunately I just didn't spot
this with so little time but the nice
thing here is if King takes H2 and queen
takes F4 and White's whole position is
crumbling because I'm hitting the king
winning back the Knight I just have a
massive attack uh if I were to find
Knight takes H2 white probably shouldn't
take the Knight but um I'm ready to take
the bishop F4 is still hanging and this
is pretty much just winning for black
engine gives a big Plus in Black's favor
so unfortunately I miss that I took on
F4 the position is still good but after
he plays knf three I made a a pretty bad
misjudgment here what I should have
realized is White's King is much more
vulnerable and usually when the king or
the opponent's king is less safe you
should not trade Queens but I went for
the queen trade thinking that I'm up a
pawn and I'm down on time so I might as
well try and simplify into an end game
but this allowed white to come back into
the game uh what I should have played
here is just Retreat the queen keep the
queen on this diagonal and then I'm
threatening to take the Knight and still
generate some mating ideas and the
position is still very very good for
black up a pawn with a lot of attacking
potential but once I took the queen and
then I took the Knight um leading to a
position where white has two Bishops
against two knights then the momentum
very quickly shifted and it was white
putting on the pressure even though I'm
still up a pawn it didn't really feel
like it now I was trying to trade um I
really wanted to trade Rooks but he
avoided the Traer Rooks and we got to a
position where I was
a little bit Shish kebabbed along the
the defile I move my king to defend the
Knight but at this point I had 3 seconds
left and playing on the one sec
increment is not really enough I just
completely miss the threat of Bishop
A5 um now it turns out there was only
one move to survive in this position so
if you want to try and find it feel free
to pause the video I'm not sure if I
would have found the move even if I had
more time time uh but the only move is
King to B6 now this prevents Bishop A5
but it allows Bishop F1 which looks to
win material because my knight is pinned
and attacked
twice but this would be okay for black
this is actually preferable for black if
I were to find the followup Knight E4
counterattacking the bishop and
preparing Knight
ef2 to save the pinned Knight
and if a move like Bishop takes G7 is
played I can still play this hitting the
Rook threatening Rook G8 and it's
actually black who is winning in this
position so yeah it was a tough sequence
to find and unfortunately yeah once I
plundered Bishop A5 it went downhill
very quickly I do want to note that uh
in this moment maybe I could have tried
King B8 but doesn't really help black
because after Bishop to E7 there's no
way to stop Bishop D6 I'm a little bit
too slow with counterplay and yeah
there's no way to uh use my Knights to
save the situation of my
king so I decided not to resign in the
game because I thought it'd be funny to
try and set up some stalemate trap um
but he actually mentioned at some point
during the game that he was aware of the
possibility of stalemate I think he
mentioned it at the beginning but then
also towards the end
too and my Hope was to have him like get
in a situation where he sacks a queen
for my Pawn like if we were to get to
this position then I would try to play
King h8 hoping he would pre-move some
pawn move expecting me to recapture but
yeah that didn't happen he played Queen
F6 and then I got mated so that was a
game I think it was a really cool fight
I hope there's lessons to take away it's
always cool playing Magnus now Magnus
did have something to say right after
the game can we see how you you won or I
can check the was pretty adorable he
called the game pretty
terrible but let me know what you think
in the comments uh if it was a terrible
game maybe for his standards but I think
for my standards playing against a goat
it was uh maybe a story to tell my
grandchildren so hope you enjoyed the
video stay tuned for more